on poursuit avec le ministre de la santé
monsieur dubé bonsoir bonsoir je devais
vous avez dit ce qui se passe nous
préoccupe qu'est ce qui vous préoccupe
ben c'est sûr que la montée des corps
nous préoccupe parcours on n'a pas vu
encore d'impact majeur sur les
hospitalisations alors c'est ce qu'il
faut on le dit depuis plusieurs semaines
c'est ça qu'on doit survenir bon je vais
vous montrer un tableau justement 14
décembre 2021 et 14 décembre 2020 il y
avait 1 890 hospitalisé ce lien à 293 1
890 c'est le maximum qu'on peut plus
jamais dépassé ce que c'est ça aussi et
même plus bas que ben il faut regarder
si le nombre de listes une chose mais
d'avoir le personnel pour pouvoir les
desservir nos patients à ce moment notre
maximum l'ico vide de sens faire du
délestage additionnels dans nos
chirurgie ou dans nos urgences c'est ça
un petit peu plus que 800 alors c'est
pour ça qu'il faut pas se rapprocher
trop de ce chef né et avoir d'autres
impacts sur le réseau mais vos experts
vous disent qu'avec l'entrée de le micro
on pourrait atteindre ce seuil de
spécialisation à quel moment
beaucoup plus en janvier-février
département de la sq ont appris que le
ne varia au micro est beaucoup plus
contagieux donc il va rechercher les
gens plus rapidement mais on n'est pas
encore certain de sa sévérité alors ça
veut pas dire que les gens iraient plus
à l'hôpital alors il ya encore beaucoup
d'hypothèses navire fuit dans les
prochaines semaines mais pour être
certain c'est pour ça qu'on a dit
aujourd'hui qu'il fallait en plus
accéléré la troisième dose parce qu'une
chose qui est certaine c'est que la
troisième dose à dose de rappel va
permettre aussi des plus efficaces pour
vaincre au micro quand ce sera avec nous
ben justement pour la troisième dose le
québec est un peu en retard par rapport
à l'ontario par exemple ou et c'est la
population générale nous ses 70 ans et
plus où les travailleurs de la santé et
si en janvier les 60 ans et plus il ya
pas moyen d'accélérer sa en fait oui
mais ça nous prend plus de vaccinateurs
en gros là on vaccine à peu prends ce
moment à 300 à 1000 personnes par
semaine si on se remet l'été dernier où
lorsqu'on d'actions au maximum en
vacciner à peu près 800 à 1000 personnes
par semaine alors si pour vous dire
qu'en ce moment on voudrait vacciner
plus mon est limité par le nombre de
vaccinateurs avez-vous la thur envoyé
trop vite déjà la maison les gens des
gens voulaient arrêter des gens note
6/10 snowboard se retourner en floride
c'est des gens qui disent eh ben moi
c'est un âge fait ça j'ai fait ma part
les combine ces on a retourné du
personnel qui était dans les
vaccinateurs on les a retourné dans les
hôpitaux on les a retourné dans nos
groupes de médecine familiale pour que
la machine continue à prendre des rendez
vous etc alors comment va faire pour la
troisième dose ciapa 500 nouvelles
personnes qui cognait à la porte ben il
va moi je suis certain qu'il va en avoir
parce que des gens sont sont pas toutes
parties en floride justement piano qui
vont peut-être avoir pris deux trois
semaines un mois de repos qui qui ont
été jusqu'à maintenant excessivement
collaborateurs on dit qu'à chaque sens
vaccinateurs chaque sens vaccinateurs on
va chercher cent mille personnes par
semaine c'est que c'est beaucoup alors
chaque fois qu'on va les chercher cent
mille personnes de plus ont lieu trois
semaines si on est à 400 milles mais je
fais mes travailleurs de la santé plus
rapidement je fais mes personnes
vulnérables plus rapidement et plus on
va aller chercher la troisième dose plus
on va se protéger quand un homme micron
qui serait probablement très présent à
janvier ce qui frappe à monsieur dubé
sait comment à chaque opération on est
au bout de la corde dans tout le il
manque des infirmières et manquent de
tout le délestage pas fini vous êtes
l'on va aller arracher 500 personnes
comment ça se fait que notre système est
si et tire mais ce parce qu'on les tire
depuis longtemps et je veux pas faire de
politique aujourd'hui pas le temps mais
ça fait 20 ans qu'on est pour moi d'où
je viens dans des entreprises ou les
organisations que j'ai géré faut
toujours avoir 10 à 15% de plus du
personnel qu'on a besoin pour pallier
aux imprévus l'an 9 20% de moins de
personnel qu'il faut on n'a pas 15% de
son de 20% moi c'est qu'on est toujours
mouchon comme on appelle quand on va et
c'est pour ça qu'on veut on veut ce
changement de culture là on veut ramener
des gens pour dire l'environnement de
travail pour être meilleur plus a déjà
qu'ils vont viser fermière monsieur
dubois et pardonnez moi mais ça pas
marcher beaucoup votre appel
de vous êtes presque miage nous en
remettre l'argent n'a pas su nous mettre
à genoux gens mettent à genoux mais jean
vous dire deux choses premièrement on a
déjà ramené 2500 jeudi sur les 4000
qu'on cherchait il y en à 2005 qui sont
déjà là mais on n'en prend plus alors il
ya aussi des choses qu'on va améliorer
après des discussions justement sur le
terrain parlent aux syndicats il y avait
des éléments dans notre programme de
rappel cours de 20 il y aurait par
exemple les congés sans solde des choses
comme ça on a tout corriger ça et l'on
leur remet devant les employés et on
leur donne un mot c'est à dire qu'on
leur donne jusqu'à la mi janvier lorsque
le je pense que les aménagements
convient de faire sont très importants
ils vont aider déjà revenir à des coûts
bon vous avez annoncé
d'abord vous avez dit c'est pas terminé
en voulant zen on espérait que ça soit
terminé que beaucoup de gens qui nous et
qu'on veut tous qu'ils espéraient que ça
soit terminé un peu et c'est pas terminé
et donc vous êtes allé jusqu'à dire le
télétravail les entreprises du québec
ramenez votre monde en télétravail
est pour quelque chose de décourageant
totalement là d'un bel été moi je dis
souvent qu'il faut rester en avant de la
parade c'est sûr que c'est pas des
décisions faciles mais ça c'était la
plus évidente savez-vous à chaque fois
qu'on a un nouveau variant ce qu'on veut
c'est une limiter le nombre de contacts
ne va rien ne se se raffole des contacts
entre les personnes alors faut éviter
les contacts alors est un endroit milieu
de travail où c'est facile d'éviter les
contacts qu'on le montre et on aimerait
en présentiel vous et moi la première
fois première fois mais ça convient pas
qu'on fait des entrevues pour ma part en
part par tings ou pas alors donc c'est
ça qu'il faut dire pendant un certain
temps dans limitant les contacts pour
éviter les écoles allez vous me voyez
venir limitons les contacts la semaine
dernière j'avais un docteur à rawdon
entrevue mdi vraies personnes
d'abandonner la pression aurait
plusieurs 25 15 10 là allez vous reculez
la tuer ou vous allez dire dans le fond
tu voyais est le plus responsable
possible un peu plus touchés c'est ce
qu'on a dit la semaine passée soyons
clairs on a du retard ou de jusqu'à 20
personnes on n'est pas obligé d'aller
sur le maximum mais en ce moment il
fallait aussi avoir l'adhésion déjà
remboursé vous vous êtes année mais
aussi je tenais plus tout le monde et
année on se fie à leur bon jugement des
québécois qui ont été très digne
maintenant revenir avec d'autres ont
crypté c'est sûr que si on avait 4000
hospitalisation demain non mais qui
arrivera pause arrive repos mais ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'en ce moment on
voit pas de raison de le faire mais je
vais vous dire aussi qu'on a des fois on
s'est ajusté très rapidement si la
situation change et en ontario là ils
viennent de passer à au-dessus de 20% du
cac au micro de corinne grand pardon il
y en avait pas de trois semaines qu
alors faut juste avec prudent dans
l'ajustement qu'on doit pas nous avons
posé la question différemment monsieur
dupont si vous aviez eu à prendre la
décision aujourd'hui pour noël sachant
ce que vous savez sur le micro auriez
vous donner le feu vert à 20 personnes
oui la réponse est oui quand même quand
même parce qu'il était important de
garder l'adhésion des gens pour tous
particulièrement ceux qui ont décidé de
se faire vacciner puis de dire des fois
on a besoin d'un petit cadeau on a
besoin de se faire plaisir vingt
personnes vaccinées qui se voit noël
c'est correct et voilà parce que même si
javier interdit on peut se demander si
les québécois avait su on aurait suivi
mais c'est ça puisse déjà qu'ils seront
vaccinés qu'ils voient entre garder orné
on était ensemble mais il faut le faire
dans un environnement correct et je
pense qu'en ce fia jusqu'à maintenant au
jugement des québécois on assez bien ri
un petit mot avant de vous laisser aller
sur les tests rapides
pour ceux qui ont des symptômes pour les
enfants pas pour moi je m'amuse et au
corps spawn alcootest non mais c'est ça
et la bonne nouvelle c'est grand damne
beaucoup parce qu'on en oeuvre on en a
donné oui mais on a déjà donné aux
parents pour ceux qui ont des enfants en
service de garde aux écoles on l'a
nominée dans des packs sacs des enfants
puis en plus le fédéral s'est engagé à
nous en envoyer un autre 3 millions dans
les prochains jours pour d'ici le 20
décembre
alors tous sont mis ensemble mais on va
expliquer pour des belles vidéos qui
expliquent comment faire l'autotest
parce qu'on s'est envolé vers le loto
dépistage gratuit partout gratuite haut
niveau dans une bassine par faire
inutilement vous dire voilà quand on est
symptomatique c'est à dire on est un nez
qui coule on a des seins tombent un à un
le fait qu'après son pour aller vérifier
dans un centre de dépistage on a vu le
petit vidéo le pis les gens vont pouvoir
les regarder ça c'est pas très compliqué
aussi simple jésus belge passe on se
reparlera mais sinon je vous souhaite de
joyeuses fêtes quand même malgré tout ça
il faut on va passer à travers puis on
va voir on va avoir un beau temps des
frais de timbre merci monsieur merci à
la prochaine heure sans beaucoup pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit